what I want to do in this video is think
a little bit about what numbers really
represent so let's say someone were to
write down the number 25 so what does
this really mean well the five here this
is in the ones place so it literally
represents five ones and this two right
over here this is in the tens place this
is in the tens place so let me write
that down
that's the tens place that's the ones
place so this represents two tens what
do I mean by that well another way to
write this is this - this says this
represents two tens so let me write that
down
this is equal to two two tens plus plus
5 ones plus five ones
now what are two tens well that's
literally if you could imagine a ten
being a block of ten things so you could
imagine if this is a ten right over here
let me copy and paste this so copy so
this is going to be the same thing this
is going to be equal to you have your
two tens so 110 and two tens so you have
your two tens
so that's your two tens right over there
that really represents 20 plus your five
ones plus plus your five ones well if
this is a one right over here and I'm
just representing it as kind of one
vertical bar five ones are going to look
like we're going to have one two - I
think you see where this is going three
four four and five and five and so these
are all different ways of representing
the same quantity 25 is two tens and
five ones this is this two is in the
tens place the five is in the ones place
so two tens plus five ones
so you could view this as two groups of
ten plus five groups
of or five ones right over here and what
is this going to be the same thing as
well two groups of ten this is the same
thing as 20 and this over here is equal
to five so once again all ways to
represent 25 you could view this as two
tens plus five ones
or you could view this you could view
this as twenty let me write this down
25 you could view because this two is
two tens that represents 20 plus the
five ones plus five ones